montagmorgen in berlin erster schultag
nach den ferien viele fragen sind noch
offen
in der julia glaube ich vielleicht noch
in der 3
gut findet der 4
leider lassen sich nicht alle offenen
fragen zum schulstart so leicht klären
und während sich die kinder darauf
freuen ihre freunde wiederzutreffen
machen sich viele eltern sorgen ob die
schulen wirklich auf den normalbetrieb
unter corona bedingungen vorbereitet
sind
wie man schule und ruhezeiten richtig
machen kann dann ist die zeit natürlich
nicht gut genutzt worden also die
bundesliga hat sich sehr viel früher da
gekümmert wie die spieler wieder
ausfällt der schulleiter der anderen
schule hat über die ferien versucht sein
haus so gut wie möglich auf den neustart
vorzubereiten
dennoch hat er bedenken wenn in den
klassenräumen alle wie gewohnt platz
nehmen
das ist voll und das ist eng und das ist
es auch wenn wir keine coop 19 pandemien
25 kinder sollen hier ab dieser woche
wieder unterrichtet werden von
abstandsregeln ist keine rede mehr
jetzt natürlich mit der prämisse
regelunterricht soll wieder stattfinden
ist es auch nachvollziehbar versuchen
wir den regelbetrieb wieder zu starten
es gibt keine expertise wie erfolgreich
das sein wird wir versuchen ein stück
weit den blindflug wir denke ich wir
sind als team zwar gut vorbereitet aber
wir sind trotzdem sehr angespannt und
sehr konzentriert angespannte lehrer
verunsicherte eltern und schulleiter die
das gefühl haben nach den sommerferien
im blindflug zu starten
dabei hatten sich die meisten zunächst
gefreut als die präsidentin der
kultusministerkonferenz mitte juni
verkündete wir haben gemeinsam
beschlossen dass wir zum regulären
schulbetrieb nach den ferien
zurückkehren wollen regulärer
schulbetrieb in allen 16
kultusministerien wurde das zum neuen
lieblings begriff regelbetrieb
regelbetrieb welcher betrieb
regelbetriebs regelbetrieb regelbetrieb
wie das allerdings gehen soll regelt
seither wieder jedes bundesland
sich beispiel masken pflicht in
nordrhein westfalen gilt diese ab klasse
5 sogar im unterricht in anderen
bundesländern heißt es ab klasse eins
masken pflicht auf gängen oder schulhof
in weiteren ländern erst ab klasse 5
wieder andere begnügen sich damit die
maske lediglich zu empfehlen und
sachsen-anhalt teilt mit man beobachte
die debatte und werde vor schulstart
entscheiden entscheidungen kurz vor
schulstart genau das befürchten viele
schulleiter in nordrhein westfalen
beispielsweise hatte der direktor der
bertha von suttner schule in siegen
eigentlich das gefühl gut vorbereitet zu
sein
dann kam die masken pflicht im
unterricht wir selbst haben ja da haben
wir als erwachsene erfahrungen beim
museumsbesuch zwei stunden maske auf zu
haben dann ist aber auch wirklich genug
und deswegen planen die schulen jetzt
schon alle möglichen modelle wie kriegen
wir es hin dass die kinder zwischendurch
mal luft runkel
die schulen müssen überlegen wie sie die
kinder zwischendurch in kleinen gruppen
auf den hof schicken doch das wiederum
kostet zeit die nicht eingeplant war
für eine solche große schule braucht man
ungefähr drei wochen um einen
vernünftigen unterrichtsplan zu haben
der kann jetzt nicht geändert werden wir
müssen jetzt sehen wie wir mit der neuen
situation umgehen dabei war es schon
kompliziert genug die bisherigen
hygienevorgaben einzubauen
beispielsweise das stoßlüften nach jeder
stunde bei geöffneter fenster ein
sicherheitsrisiko darstellen müssen die
schüler in dieser zeit den raum
verlassen
ähnliche schwierigkeiten in vielen
schulen bundesweit weil die
abstandsregeln nicht mehr gelten setzen
die kultusministerien vor allem auf die
so genannte kohorten lösung ein jahrgang
also beispielsweise die fünften klassen
bilden dabei eine kohorte die möglichst
immer in den gleichen räumen
unterrichtet wird damit sie den schülern
der anderen kurorten nicht begegnet in
fachräumen wir einen chemiesaal aber
sitzen in kurzer folge schüler aus allen
kurorten hinzu kommt die lehrer wechseln
zwischen den klassenstufen in der großen
pause
begegnen sie sich dann im lehrerzimmer
auch hier ist der mindestabstand kaum
einzuhalten
unter diesen umständen anzunehmen meine
infektion ließe sich auf eine kur orte
beschränken ist zumindest optimistisch
was machen wir wenn wir schulen
schließen müssen ob diese pläne dafür
man spricht auch vom plan b oder plan c
ob die im ministerium vorhanden sind
kann ich nicht beurteilen aber
jedenfalls sind sie nicht kommuniziert
worden
es wäre sicherlich hilfreich wenn da
mehr konzepte da liegen dass man
beruhigter in die situation geben kann
in mecklenburg vorpommern dauerte es
gerade mal vier tage bis die ersten
beiden schulen wieder geschlossen werden
mussten
in schleswig holstein hat eine schule
gar nicht erst geöffnet wie stattdessen
unterricht digital zu hause stattfinden
soll ist auch nach den ferien meist
unklar
genau das kritisiert verena poster sieht
man jetzt bei den schulstart stunden
dass wir die sommerferien nicht dafür
genutzt haben zu überlegen wie können
wir denn jetzt konzepte in der schublade
haben wenn die hälfte der schüler wieder
zu hause sein muss weil die
abstandsregeln vergrößert werden müssen
oder was machen wir wenn ganze schulen
wieder schließen wie aktuell in der
kernburg vorpommern
wieso wurde da keine zentrale regelung
von der kultusministerkonferenz
getroffen wie so war das wieder 16 mal
thema
das sind so beispiele wo ich denke dass
wir deutlich schneller an pragmatisch
verhalten und wann eigentlich hätte der
lockdown der schulen die große stunde
der kultusministerkonferenz sein müssen
bundesweit einheitliche digitalisierung
vernetzung der schulen stattdessen
bastelt jedes land an seiner eigenen
cloud
auch deshalb sind sie am berliner otto
nagel gymnasium froh dass sie vor elf
jahren beschlossen haben nicht mehr auf
die politik zu wahren
inzwischen arbeiten hier alle schüler
wie lehrer digital mit laptop vernetzt
über die schuleigene plattform als die
schulschließung kam konnte ab tag eins
weiter gelernt werden wir hatten halt
die laptops zu hause wie haben die
möglichkeit die mitzunehmen konnten hals
phase unsere aufgaben abrufen und sie
dann halt zu hause bearbeiten ist
natürlich ein riesen vorteil dadurch
dass wir gar keinen richtigen katrin
hatten war man immer in
schulen modus und hat auch gut gelernt
fand ich und die lehrer waren auch immer
bereit frage zu beantworten oder haben
auch sozusagen private video calls zur
verfügung gestellt wenn man eben fragen
hatte das otto nagel gymnasium ist eine
öffentliche schule entstanden ist das
alles auf initiative von eltern und
schülern weitgehend mit privaten mitteln
auf die schnelle lässt sich das nicht
kopieren
ich denke es sind dinge möglich also wie
kommunikationsstrukturen herzustellen
ich glaube das einrichten von e mails
sollte möglich sein
vielleicht auch das zurückgreifen auf
eine lernplattform aber komplett
digitale schule wird von heute auf
morgen nicht möglich sein das ist ein
prozess der jahre braucht zurück zu
matthias höhere zurück zu einer list
schule auch sie arbeiten an einer
eigenen schule plattform wollen digitale
schule am engagement scheitert es nicht
vielmehr an den zehn jahre alten
rechnern
wir bemühen uns die zwei mal von der
software ja aktuell zu halten aber wir
sind weit weg von wlan und moderner
hardware wie man sie vielleicht aus dem
freizeitbereich kennt fünf milliarden
euro hatte die bundesregierung bereit
gestellt für den digital packt doch
davon ist an den meisten schulen in
deutschland bislang nicht angekommen
krone hat noch deutlicher gemacht woran
das liegt zu viel bürokratie und
föderaler eigen sind warum muss ein
digital packt 16 mal umgesetzt werden
mit verschiedenen förderrichtlinien mit
verschiedenen anforderungen waren
konnten wir da nicht einmal zentral
festlegen welche hardware oder welche
wlan konfiguration wollen wir an den
schulen keinen grund warum ein kind in
bremen ein anderes tablet nutzen muss
als in bayern und da muss unser anspruch
aus meiner sicht in deutschland ein
anderer sein gerade wenn bildung der
einzige rohstoff ist dinge haben wenn
sich schüler eltern und lehrer nicht
einmal in der pandemie auf die
kultusministerkonferenz verlassen können
stellt sich die frage wofür man die
überhaupt braucht
[Musik]